elle est elle est longue à arriver mais
une fois qu'on a l'image on décolle plus
j'accueille maintenant gage par Proust
pour aller bordel la vie
[Applaudissements]
alors est-ce qu'on peut rire de tout oui
mais pas avec n'importe qui non pas du
coup ce qui explique sans doute pourquoi
c'est très dur de rire des de tout avec
les gens de gauche c'est vous n'êtes pas
de gauche ah non non vous êtes beaucoup
trop excitante pour ça
non vraiment c'est rare de alors bien
sûr est-ce qu'on pourrait dire
aujourd'hui ce que disait autrefois les
anciens les Inconnus Coluche des proches
Raymond Barre Félix Potin est-ce qu'on
peut se permettre ça non évidemment mais
pourquoi on ne peut pas bah faut être
honnête aujourd'hui au siècle des
Lumières comiques nous autres les
énarques de la galéjade nous les
normalisiens du jeu de mots du
ricanement académique nous les futurs
inconnus j'ai autrefois les sketchs
étaient décortiqués par Bouvard Martin
aujourd'hui tu as vu on ferait
Finkielkraut BHL
Caron qui est leur maître à penser à
tous bien sûr alors pourquoi aujourd'hui
et pas hier et ben parce qu'il faut
croire que les humoristes étaient
incapables d'avoir une pensée autrefois
ils étaient beaucoup plus cons
alors sinon quoi d'autre de lecture
alors épilogue des Feux de l'Amour donc
Élisée c'est fini et je suis un peu déçu
et choqué je suis choqué vous direz Anne
franchement vu que c'est lui qui se fait
prendre la main dans le sac normalement
quand c'est l'homme qui quitte la femme
c'est lui qui quitte le domicile
conjugal qu'est-ce qu'il faut aller
Lisée
alors quand elle a pris l'adultère
trireveler a déclaré j'ai eu
l'impression de tomber du haut d'un
gratte-ciel non mais c'est la crue
tombée d'un immeuble on tient au moins
une certitude elle va rebondir
et après la lanterne elle est partie se
reposer en Inde alors lui est parti en
Turquie bon alors attendez pas de moi
que je fasse une blague sur les
toilettes turques c'est vraiment pas du
niveau non vraiment même si c'est quand
même grâce à ce système qu'on comprend
pourquoi la Turquie a toujours été très
bien placée dans les compétitions
internationales en haltérophilie
[Rires]
ouais elle est longue à arriver mais une
fois qu'on a l'image on décolle plus
alors lui son côté évidemment on le sent
plus sûr de lui il y a quelque chose qui
moi déjà je m'identifie beaucoup plus
quoi la manière qu'il a eu de renvoyer
sa meuf on aurait dit moi face un plan
cul tu sais j'ai décidé en totale accord
avec moi-même qu'il est 1h du matin que
j'ai déjà joué et que je dors mieux
quand je dors tout seul
alors on lui reproche d'avoir utilisé le
jeu le jeu un peu de patience avec
l'assurance qu'il est en train de
prendre ce qui il va surprendre la
prochaine intervention il va il va pas
il va parler de lui à 3e personne ça
sera lui président enfin il le sait il
choisira qui va partager son pieu stop
ça suffit les minutes tu dégages oui lui
président il dira oui je te veux je ne
te veux plus oui la comédien pousse toi
viens la journaliste et par ici la
danseuse du Crazy Cholet marrant
poussez-vous j'ai voulu les faire
lui président il n'aversera pas la coupe
du chômage comme j'ai prévu non désolé
j'ai échoué je t'emmerde c'est comme ça
je suis ce que je veux
lui président il dirait un ajout de la
location c'est bien tes lois contre le
sexisme mais moi je suis un ado je suis
libre casse pas les murs
car lui président enfin il le sait
maintenant il le dit
je dis non car je suis à l'adolescent et
l'adolescence on dit non alors non lui
présentera pas les illisés il se lèvera
midi il n'ira pas au séminaire sous la
parité et non le Président il fera pas
du socialisme fera du tas de chair juste
pour faire caca sur le mouton voilà
[Applaudissements]
jour de colère les manifs sujets un peu
de temps j'ai vu ça c'est chaud c'est
moi je sais pas si je vais sur après je
reste quelqu'un de prosaïque et simple
dans cette manif on a vu des slogans
antisémites homophobes et c'est pas bien
à l'autre côté il faut reconnaître que
dans les manifs de gauche il y a souvent
des slogans antifascistes oui
il y a tort qui a raison je suis pas
assez intelligent pour trancher
je sais pas anniversaire Clara Morgane
est né à 25 janvier comme Jean-Marc
Ayrault comme quoi l'astrologie c'est
vraiment de la merde
[Applaudissements]
Marseille réglement de compte entre
trafiquants un homme a été abattu à la
kalachnikov devant son fils
va faire rire avec ça
alors le fils a été épargné bon c'est
normal le gamin il a vu l'agresseur il a
dit ah c'est pas moi c'est lui
bonne nouvelle alors il paraît que
Schumacher se réveille doucement de
façon faut pas trop le brusquer c'est
normal tu imagines tu dis un champion
international domicilié à Monaco bonjour
tu es soigné à Grenoble non non
en plus c'est un Allemand quoi le
Vercors n'est pas loin
c'est pas que des bons souvenirs pour
ces gens-là alors elle est pas belle la
vie et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
[Musique]
un pouce bleu